and get started. Welcome to another Zoom call. It is the third of August, 2022.
I think this month marks the sixth or the seventh year we've been doing these Zoom calls.
And I think we missed, I think we may have missed four. That's pretty good, pretty good stats there.
And now we've added a second Zoom call. So always reminder between Zoom calls and such. Look for the
in our website, not on our membership site, but on our website, you can search for questions that you
might have that might already have blog posts. And I hope that everybody on this call is on our
membership site because that's where you should be submitted questions. So on the membership pages,
I really apologize, I haven't really been cold. So on the membership pages, that's where you can
submit questions. Everybody's doing a good job of doing that lately. So submit your questions
on there and those will be make sure that we get them. Remember, we've added another Zoom call
with Ann. So questions that come in and they answer them and they will be recorded as they have been.
And they are put up on the membership site as well. If you have a question specifically for Ann,
just to say, Ann in the question box, Ann please answer this or specifically for me, you could say
Dr. Counters, please answer this. It will both do our best. All right, let's jump to the questions.
To keep family happy, to know where my cancer is at, try to balance family and health.
Out is really hard. Yeah, it certainly is. You pulled in lots of different direction.
As I do respect their emotions, but medical is not my first choice. So lots of emotions are going wild.
You do not have to post this part. Well, I'm sorry, I just copied and pasted this whole thing
this first time I'm reading this. So, but I think everybody relates to that.
You know, you get you torn by, you know, a spouse or a family member or your mother or father or sister or
brother that's like, you need to go to the oncologist, you need to do this or you need to do that or you're
going to die. We have some videos on our blog post about how to deal with those kind of things.
I made a video and I think Michelle made a video and we have several blog posts at how to deal
with the questions that you get. You know, people, you know, you're choosing a way of care that might
be different. I've said this multiple times and I write this in the book that my belief is that
a lot of people will push you down the path of standard of care not because they necessarily believe in
it, but because it absorbs, absorbs them of the responsibility to help you.
Just go to the oncologist because honestly, game trusser, just go to the oncologist so
that I don't have to worry about it. So, it doesn't work while you die while they did everything they
can. And I don't have to think about it. I don't have to support you really. I don't have to,
you know, study up on this. I don't have to help you make juices or, you know, it just
absorbs them of their responsibility and there's a lot of guilt of family members when somebody
they love is ill. And you see this with the elderly, you see children of, you know, families,
children will come and say, we need to just put Bob in the nursing home. We just need to put
Bob in this. We just need to do this. Just follow what the doctor gave said. Just get
her on these medications. Usually it's the it's the family member that did nothing to help mom
for the last 15 years. It just is what it is. There's psychology and that is around this.
That makes people feel better. If you're just doing what the oncologist said to do,
then it just kind of takes away any responsibility on their part.
We went to the Cancer Treatment Center of America with my breast tumor as large as it is. They put
me on Femera. I have read and listened to lots of your information on this and wondering if the
dim products are comparable. So the dim products and other aroma taste inhibitors are very
beneficial. But like I've said, over and over again, nothing is going to compare to a drug that's
going to shut down all your estrogen. Go back again to here and search, just start typing
aroma taste that I have multiple articles on different aroma taste inhibitors, natural aroma taste
inhibitors. That can help get rid of bad estrogens. Remember you have over 33 different estrogen
metabolites in your body all the time. And if you do a full estrogen progesterone androgen panel
as a female, you're going to see there's normal levels of all these metabolites. And it's just the
quote-unquote bad estrogens that end up attaching to the estrogen receptors that can block apoptosis,
causing you to have what's called a ER positive cancer. So the medical model is to just
shut down all estrogen. It makes you feel lousy and gives you all sorts of side effects that a lot of
women don't like. But yes, you could look at some of the dim products. There's astroclear, which is a
mark-linked product that can be very beneficial. There's fermented soy products. We just came up with
another dim product that has calcium degluterate and a couple other things in it. So there's many
things that you could look at for that. But I'd suggest go back to the blogs.
Is there something else that could help with the side effects if I do end up taking it? So if you
take an estrogen blocker, you can have the side effects of being in complete menopause. And you
will have hot flashes and not feeling well and no energy and some weight gain and all these kind
of things. No, there really isn't anything that you could do to help with that. That's going to
help tremendously because the symptoms are because of estrogen just being taked. And if you're
yeah, you could give some estrogen stimulants, but then you're reversing what you're trying to do
with the drug. So if you're going to choose to do something with the drug, then you can't really do
that. You can use some, use some adrenal support and adaptogens. So usually people that are on
any type of hormone blocking drugs, whether it's males with prostate cancer and energy deprivation
there, therapy or females on a robotace blocking drugs, any other estrogen blocking drugs, using
adaptogens is really the first thing to go to, but it's not going to really make a giant mark in the
symptoms. It can help with the fatigue and such though. They also put the eye brands. So eye brands
is another daily chemotherapy drug that's that's become very popular in the last five years.
Once again, I'm not impressed, but hoping this could be short term. We are having test results
sent to you. I was hoping to wait until after the genetic testing came back. Exiting is very
high right now. Well, that's where the adaptogens will help. So think of adaptogenic herbs. So we have
a corticlear. That's a great adaptogen for what we're talking about here and adaptoclear. That's
another great adaptogen. They're very different. They have different things in them. So you have to
try some of these to see what's going to work for you. Seems like matter what I take, I wake up around
two or three. You can't rest the mind to get back to sleep. So adaptogenic herbs are what I would suggest.
And I can pull up some of those pictures for you as well. That might help. You just go to our store
and search corticlear. You'll see that it's a product that could be very helpful for this. So
well, that didn't work. There. That's what it looks like. So corticlear. Okay. I am having
abdomen and hip pain so bad that last night I resorted to taking Tylenol and an hour and a half later
taking ibuprofen. So I could get some sleep. I slept better than I have for the last year. Well,
that's fantastic. I know these are bad for the liver and kidney. So I usually stay away from them.
I've tried the rife for rotator cuff pain in the past and got no relief. And I run my rife
overnight programs while I sleep. So I can't really run pain programs that. Yeah, the rife
pain programs are very, very mixed results. I am wondering what I could use to control the pain
of the future. I rebound, weight train, and walk for miles daily as sitting still or trying to sleep
is when it gets unbearable. You do, so if it's specific, hip pain on one side, you do,
I suggest you do want to kind of get to the cause of it. If the abdominal pain is from the cancer,
that's one thing that we know that that's what's going on. We want to make sure that hip pain,
you want to see why I always want to ask the question why first. So is the hip pain from
from, you know, something going on in the hip? That's a possibility, right? So getting it x-ray
the hip would be a good idea. You know, getting a scan of that area might be a good idea of just
giving some suggestions. There are some emotional ties to the hip. If you look up emotions to
different parts of the area, the emotion of the hip is fear of moving forward. It's kind of you
walking if your hip is involved with you moving forward. So think of some emotional pieces that might
be tied to that as well. So that's a possibility. So you always want to be digging for the reason why
and yes, if, you know, a medication over the color of medication is helping you, that's great. But
again, Tylenol and ibuprofen, if you're going to do that on a daily basis, well, that can't end up
getting hard on your liver. But then you have to weigh that out with how much of, you know,
importance is there to getting a good night's sleep, too. So taking Tylenol or ibuprofen on a,
you know, regular basis where you're taking a lot of it can be problematic, but doing it on a
on a symptomatic basis where it can help you once in a while. You got to say, that could be a
blessing, too. I use a true knife every night and know that you only recommend that brand,
but I'm considered by an affordable device called the tritity. Biomedic tritity is the advanced
effective wellness technology of multi frequency synchronization. I like it because you can wear it
during the day. Would that be okay to use the rife at night and wear one with similar technology
during the day or would that be too much? No, you could certainly do that. I would be careful
false advertising. That's out there. Mike, a true rife tried to come out with a wearable device.
I was trying to help him a little bit in that process. This was about four or five years ago. He
did come up with a wearable device, but with testing, it just didn't penetrate the body,
so it didn't really make a difference, but it's not penetrating the body and it's not going to
really help the person. So I don't think he even sells it anymore. So I just don't know the efficacy
of some of these things. I've never tested that one. I don't know. Maybe it's great. So I'm not
here to knock some other person's product. Maybe it's a great product. Give it a try. I would think
that a wearable device might be better for biotoxins than for cancer, but hey, you could run it on
parasites and things like that. That's always a side thing that could be going on with cancer
anyhow. So I would say that's what you really feel led to. I don't think there's any problem. There
certainly isn't a problem with doing too much of something, so with frequency. So
I have bouts of swollen feet and ankles. The pain is so severe. I can't walk. Is there anything
I could do? And we talked about this. I think last week or the week before, to somebody else
had this question. Again, remember how do your feet and ankles drain? So swollen feet and ankles
comes from fluid. That's not draining back through the lymph system. So you always have movement
of fluid through your body. Everything in your body is about movement. So when fluid is not moving,
you have what's called stasis. So stasis of fluid fluid is is not getting back through the lymph
system. And again, remember, the lymph system is an open-ended capillary system that has one-way
valves. So as you contract your muscles, the fluid squishes through those vessels and then can't get
back down. And every time you contract your muscles, it squishes through, it squishes through and pushes
it back up your lymph system, but open it in capillaries that then drain back into the venous system.
And then out back through the liver and through the kidneys for you to expel these, this waste.
So typically, what do you do with swollen feet and ankles? You think of rest. So you're not
standing on your feet where gravity is pulling the fluid down and being able to end up in your
feet and ankles. So rest elevation in elevating your legs so that you have gravity working in your
favor. And then some of the other things, ice, can be helpful with this. But also what people forget
is lymph moves my action of your muscles. So writing the alphabet with your toes, with your ankles.
When you do stand up, do leg razors. Up on your toes, back down, up on your toes, back down. You have
to contract your lower muscles of your lower leg, your gastrocnemius, and your soleus muscles.
And your anterior muscles of your lower leg, you just got to be doing some exercise. So if you're
going to be up, it's worse thing to be just standing. It's better to be moving or walking or doing some
little exercises than what you're down, try to get your feet up so you can get fluid. Gravity
helping to move that fluid. True rife cells, a sleep cover for the rife machine is this item
simply used to reduce the illumination of light or doesn't provide protection from the blue light
waves. It's just to really to block the light from the machine itself. You could do the same thing with
the towel. So, but the sleep cover fits nicely over it and very neat if that's if the light is a
bother you. Also, please address light sources while sleeping. Should a person sleep in a totally dark
room is the light from clocks, light switches, night lights, humidifiers, a more potential health hazard.
Well, there's some sleep experts quote unquote that will say you can have any light in the room.
whatsoever, you should sleep in a completely dark room. That's how we were meant to sleep.
I just struggle with that. That's how we were meant to sleep when our ancestors slept under the
stars. Certainly, it wasn't completely dark. They did not have blackout curtains in their rooms.
I mean, you just look throughout history, then unless you're ancestors and slept in a cave, it was there
was light. It was probably light from a fireplace trying to keep the place warm. So I just don't I just don't
necessarily buy that analogy. But certainly if you're awake and it's keeping you awake, it can be a problem.
You can solve the problem by using a sleep mask. That can be beneficial. Some people don't like
wearing a sleep mask and that bothers them while they roll around and such. I don't mind the light from
the rifle machine. I can see mine. But sometimes I will put a towel over it or something like that to
block that light from the from the machine. Usually, if you're having sleep problems, which this was
addressed, you know, somebody else had this question of sleep problems too. It's not so much
light in the room. It has to do with other things that are going on. A person can have cortisol
problems. That's the that's the primarily the cause of sleep issues. So let's talk about sleep issues.
So if you're having trouble falling asleep, that's typically a melatonin problem. So melatonin is made
in the brain and stored in this little gland in the brain called the pedial gland. And it's released
when darkness comes. So it's the pedial gland releases that when there's releases melatonin,
when there's a diminished amount of light. So yes, you could say yes, we are living in a totally
different world. When it used to get dark, people didn't have as much on lighting as we have now that
are illuminating their house tremendously. So they're not getting pedial gland stimulation in order to get
melatonin secretions. So they're not getting as much sleep as they used to. So in that sense, yes,
too much light is a problem. But we're not talking about light in the bedroom. We're talking about
just light in the whole household. We used to live up in the woods in 280 acres, completely
absent of any electricity from any sources. We were off grid. This was years ago in the 90s
and we had caracene lamps. Well, we didn't want to use all our caracene. So in the winter time,
good as we go to bed with the kids at eight o'clock and we'd get up with the sunrise and go to work
again. So it was, you know, that's how I think our ancestors probably slept. They got more sleep
in the winter because the pedial gland secreted melatonin at an earlier time. In the summer,
it stays light till nine thirty ten o'clock in the summertime. And so most people don't go to sleep
at the same time in the summer as they do in the winter. Maybe now they do because they illuminate
their house with incandescent lighting. But back in the day, they didn't. So yes, light does play a part
of sleeping, but it's really the secretion of melatonin. Therefore, some people will take melatonin.
Sometimes they don't make enough melatonin or their pedial gland is not secreting melatonin well.
And you can get calcification of the pedial gland from all sorts of things. So sleep is going to be
impaired. So if you're having trouble falling asleep, that's a melatonin issue. It can also be a
stress issue too because anxiety can cause that as well. It can also be, you know, there's lots of
things that it can be. People have defects in their glutamine genes and they make a lot of glutamate.
Glutamate is an excitatory neurotransmitter and it's hard for them to go to sleep at night. Those
people probably should not eat any protein, you know, after a certain time. That might be a help too.
So taking melatonin, but there's another problem. People say they fall asleep just fine. But then they
wake up at two or three o'clock like this person in the previous question, then they can't get back to
sleep. And their mind is racing and they can't get their mind off things. And it's almost like they have
some OCD issues in the middle of the night. That's typically a cortisol issue, not a melatonin issue.
Melatonin helps you fall asleep. It doesn't help you stay asleep. Cortisol helps you stay asleep.
It gets a little technical, but your brain needs glucose at night and you have used up all your
glucose stores by about one, two, three o'clock in the morning and you have to release cortisol
from your adrenal glands to break down the glucose from glycogen stores to your liver.
So glycogen is a complex carbohydrate the way we store glucose in our liver.
For need, especially at night. So cortisol breaks down that glycogen so our brain can stay alive at night.
So when we're under a lot of stress, we're burning cortisol during the day and we can have a
deficiency of cortisol at night. And that's what wakes us up. We're full of anxiety. And we're running
basically off of glutamates at night and our mind is racing. So go back to a product like this one,
the cordoclear, which has meant to help clear and balance cortisol. That can help taking that
during the day and then dealing with all the emotional issues that you might be dealing with as well.
So there's different issues with sleep issues and I know I made some videos about that at some point
in time. My diet protocol requires that I do not eat dairy. I ask, I wanted to ask if dairy that is raw,
or the A2 dairy would be acceptable. So there's this A2 type gene that certain cows have
that helps people. They can drink that dairy if they're lactose intolerant.
Some people even with caseena tolerance can drink milk from that type of cow and they don't have
as much reaction to it. But this is not the case when we're talking about cancer. So cancer fed through
dairy has nothing to do with how it's processed or pasteurized. Therefore, whether it's raw or not
makes no difference whatsoever, nor the genetic makeup of the cow. Because all the dairy, whether it's
raw, pasteurized, or no matter what the genetic makeup of the cow is going to have growth factors in it.
So it has nothing to do with that. So if you're supposed to be off of dairy eating raw dairy or
raw cheese or any other type of dairy products, you're still going to be the same. Even if it's goat
dairy or sheep dairy, dairy, anything that's coming out of an otter is going to have growth factors in it.
It has been at least two weeks now where I am only able to get short
times of micro sleep. Oh, there's back to another sleep question. Most of the time, I'll wake up and
are falling asleep for about a half hour. Sometimes it might be as long as two hours. Then I am awake
for a few hours. Then fall asleep again after a while. So this is very similar to what we're talking
about. If you're able to fall asleep just fine, but then you wake up and you can't go back to
sleep again. If it's only within a half hour, it still could possibly be a melatonin issue. So taking
starting with melatonin might be your starting point for this person. But definitely if you're going
wake up after a couple hours and can't go to sleep again, it's definitely a cortisol issue.
So herbal tea is typically going to be like camomile and some relaxed seed herbs that will help you
relax and help you braid, relax and fall asleep. But that's really not going to solve this problem.
You really have to deal with that cortisol issue. I know I'm that I am aged. I don't know that I'm
anxious about it. I had been at any pain at all until my foot started hurting to get yesterday.
That's what we didn't talk about. Pain can keep a person awake too. Or wake a person up too.
So but I would try something like the quarter clear.
Our chat questions. Is the white sweet potato the same as the orange sweet potato?
I don't know. You'll have to Google that and see what the glycemic index is on that.
There's a lot of different varieties of hybridized vegetables that I'm not exactly sure on.
You can just search that particular variety of potato and see what the glycemic index is.
That's really what you're looking for. How fast does it break down to glucose?
So that's what a glycemic index is. So it's indexed on glucose breaks down into glucose immediately
because it's glucose. That's has a glycemic index of 100. And then potatoes, just regular potatoes,
blue potatoes, red potatoes, white potatoes. They have a glycemic index of I think 85.
Sweet potatoes are way down low because it's a totally different family. It's a really shouldn't
be called a potato. But the white potato, sweet potato, if it's in the sweet potato family,
probably has a fairly low glycemic index. So you're probably safe on that.
I had a PET scan last Friday. Maybe results will explain and be able to inhibit. Yes.
And I am taking the homeopads for radiology and ran the clear light in heavy metal foot baths.
But I also had an iron infusion and I'm going to have two more
the next two Thursday. Should I refrain from the heavy metal detox? Because it can affect my air
transfusion. That's a good question. Maybe that's a possibility. I just don't know the answer
to that but certainly maybe that might be a good thing just to avoid that this time.
Just stay away from that for a week or so you don't want to be pulling out. So the light of thought
is here is doing the heavy metal foot baths. Is that pulling out iron? Well, iron is a heavy metal
on the periodic table. So it's possible. Yeah, it's possible. So let's just avoid that.
I've been doing TRS heavy metal detox for a week and have recently had an ache or pain in my
shin overnight. And now in my arm, I did have a rupture to kill his tendon on that side and
a broken wrist on the side of my arm hurts. Is it possible that this is a detox symptom?
Yes, it is. It's very possible as a detox symptom. It is of that uncommon
that, you know, metal. So you look at the periodic table. So if we pull up a periodic table,
you'll see that here where the elements are. This will help us understand things a little bit better.
Let's go to so periodic table of elements. So this is fun to look at sometimes, right?
You have your different there's hydrogen, helium, lithium, barium. This is sodium, magnesium.
I don't know. Can you see my cursor? What I'm doing this? Can somebody let me know? Can you see my
cursor when I'm moving it around on this slide? Yes. Good. All right. So, you know, you can look at
where's iron on this? Here's iron right here. So it's, it is with these other minerals and things.
And when you have, so calcium is over here, but calcium is put into bold when you have an injury,
like a wound, a broken bone, or you have a, you know, a wounded tendon. How your body heals that
tendon? You're going to have a greater amount of calcium laid down, but you're going to have
manganese laid down and other minerals laid down in that bone. Well, there's a chance that you're
going to have other heavy metals laid down in that bone if you have circulated heavy metals. So where
do heavy metals go if you're exposed to aluminum and, you know, different landed and mercury and
here's land right here. And where do those heavy metals go when you're exposed to it? There's
mercury right there. There could go inside of the cell if your body doesn't get rid of it, but
many times it will go into the bone. So that's where it ends up getting stored. So it can get released
because your bones are living tissue. People think you just have calcium in there and they're just
holding everything up, but calcium and minerals are going in and out of the bone constantly. Remember,
your body is all about motion. So things are moving in and out of cells, in and out of
boney tissue all the time. That's the danger of taking like the bone building drugs like is it so
better that they give injections to people because you might have the possibility of bone breakdown.
Well, it all it does is create a like a cellophane wrap around the perioste with a bone and it doesn't
allow the bone to be living in active so that bone can actually become more brittle.
And there's danger to just trapping everything inside of the bone. One of the one of the purposes of
bone is to store minerals so it buffers your blood and buffers other tissues so we can actually
become acidic because we lose that buffer inability. Did you ever put together a video on GCMAF
and neglects? No, I'm sorry, and I won't do that. I will get to that. Why does the rife machine emit
a fluorescent light from the bottom? Good question. Good question. I don't know why the F117 never
did that. I don't know why he added that on the F122. I will ask him. Is there a rife machine
program for having low blood pressure to help race it? So if you have low blood pressure, how to
increase blood pressure? I don't think so. There is heart-building programs. Typically if you have
low blood pressure, you have, from a functional perspective, you have some weakness of your heart.
So it can be weakness of your heart fatigue of the heart. So for a nutritional standpoint,
low blood pressure, you think of possible low thyroid gland, you think of possible
need for heart tissue concentrates, biotics research probably makes the best one out there.
I think it gets cytozyme H, I think that's what it is. Cytozyme H, to just give the heart more
strength. A person can have low blood pressure if they just normally had fairly low to normal blood
pressure and now they're out a lot of flaminowides, green TX tract and such. So it's actually
opening up your vessels a little bit more so your blood pressure can drop even a little bit more so.
But it can give you some shortness of breath and fatigue upon exertion that you want to address.
I would say look at strengthening the heart. Adetric otters is okay to run my RIFE
ball programs while laying on my ELF back. Yes, you can do those two things simultaneously.
Any other questions? Well, I guess we will end early today then. Do remember that you
could jump on Monday's Zoom call with Anne as well. And all of that is on the member site.
So you could jump on and Anne said she or her numbers are growing. So that's just great.
And anything she doesn't know, she'll she asks me, her offices are right next to each other. So
thank you. I hope I feel better too. This is going around up in our area.
A lot of people have those really bad cold. All right, we will see you guys next week. Again, um,
know that I'll be praying for you guys. And that's it. You just keep praying for us.
All right. Bye-bye.